bonsoir j'ai une question pour vous est
ce qu'il ya des matins où vous auriez dû
rester couchés que tout va mal tu mets
ma fin de la journée on se dit que ça va
encore mal oui mais moi j'ai à vous dire
que depuis l'automne dernier
je me dis ça tous les matins j'ai besoin
pas ça va très bien dans ma vie
l'entreprise à bien mes enfants vont
bien c'est plutôt les nouvelles qui me
bouleverse un peu en fait vous savez que
les nouvelles sont bonnes pour la région
depuis l'automne dernier et je vais vous
dire que si j'avais pu me transformer en
ours puis berne et j'arrive bien
apprécié par contre j'aurais eu tout un
choc en me réveillant au printemps
mais le comble c'est les nouvelles du 29
janvier quand le conseil du patronat
veut favoriser l'exode rural c'est un
cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar pour moi parce que
maintenant entrepreneurs le conseil du
patronat je pense qu il nous représente
puis celui qui présente les entreprises
pour favoriser un essor économique au
québec
je pense que les régions font encore
partie du québec venait nous dire qu'il
fallait quitter les régions
quand je suis arrivé en région en 90 non
je voudrais que les statistiques étaient
peu reluisant et on a travaillé très
fort au cours des dernières années pour
faire augmenter le solde migratoire qui
est encore positif cette année
alors bravo l'abitibi-témiscamingue fait
encore mais là bon le gouvernement c'est
une chose
écoutez après 4,1 ont peu changé mais le
conseil du patronat est inquiétant vous
savez la région c'est un système vivant
les structures se désorganise bien sûr
mais on peut se réorganiser aussi alors
comment essayer de prendre le contrôle
de la situation
vous savez dans le mot crise en chinois
il ya deux de symboles 1 qui signifie le
danger et l'autre qui signifie les
opportunités donc dans la crise il ya
quand même deux choses importantes
oui à le danger mais il ya des
opportunités puis à des occasions qui
peuvent se présenter pour mieux rebondir
pourquoi les fourmis
c'est un peu étrange comme tout parce
que je vous parlerai pas vraiment de la
fourmi spohr vraiment biologique
en fait elle habille la fourmi c'est un
animal intelligent collectivement mais
qui est très bas être individuellement
vous savez une fourmi tout seul qui sont
heureux c'est pas la personne l'animal
le plus intelligent par contre quand ils
travaillent ensemble ils peuvent partir
de très grandes choses puis je sais pas
le gazon chez vous you take pas de
fourmi parce qu'il y eu petit garçon
mais les délais pour mieux sonder grande
travaillant donc
partant de l'homme à linverse travail
plus individuellement ce que je vous
invite dans une profonde mutation comme
on vit présentement c'est travailler
comme les fourmis puis de faire en sorte
de faire passer les intérêts collectifs
au delà de vos intérêts personnels
alors pourquoi pas tenter le coup par
une approche de d'intelligence
collective pour assurer notre
développement
il faut vraiment se donner des règles
c'est ce que je vais vous présenter ce
soir c'est sûr que je tenais cuisinière
puis je connais pas mon livre de
recettes par k o
vous allez me permettre de regarder mes
règles pour m'assurer de vous donner les
bonnes je vous dirais que la première
chose c'est pas une règle mais la
première chose qu'il faut faire
attention puis je vous dirais qu'ils me
ce qui me désespère le plus présentement
c'est que dans l'intelligence collective
faut adopter une attitude positive et
vous savez les médias sociaux entre
autres parce que c'est instantané nous
permettent de commenter des choses et là
dans le fond c'est pas une réelle 70
prévenir ça l'intelligence collective il
faut arrêter sa beauté collectivement ce
qu'on a présentement mais plutôt adopter
une position qui collective possible
collectif qui surtout de faire renverser
la vapeur
donc utiliser les médias sociaux dans la
proche de l'ex d'intelligence collective
d'une façon positive s'il vous plaît
donc je vous présente mais cette règle
ils sont basés bien sûr sont différentes
recherches mais on a travaillé récemment
je loue avec une
une personne qui développe leadership
collaboratif donc on a eu des
discussions c'est ce que je vous
présente ce soir parce que j'y crois
profondément et j'espère que je veux
convaincre de travailler man se dans
cette optique là donc la règle numéro 1
ne pas attendre après le gouvernement
n'attendez pas après le gouvernement
vous savez la région et habitudes faire
les choses autrement et c'est ce qu'il
faut faire quand on fait de
l'intelligence collective il faut faire
de la région
l'abitibi-témiscamingue une pme qui doit
innover pour s'en sortir vous savez mon
passé était plutôt dans le secteur
public aujourd'hui chez entrepreneurs
jeu capable de faire le lien entre les
deux puis je vous garantis que si on
fait une grosse pme en abitibi
témiscamingue qui qu'on innove parce que
quand on est en affaires on n'a pas le
choix faut pas attendre après les
subventions pas tort d'après le
gouvernement
quant au contraire je voudrais qu'on va
être capable de s'en sortir il faut
surtout faire émerger leadership de
notre population pas attendre après les
leaders officiels
mais ici leur ce soir puis j'en ai
entendu depuis tantôt il ya des leaders
ici puis c'est cela qu'il faut
qu'émergent la règle numéro 2 se donner
une vision commune et partagée surtout
puis trouver qu'est-ce qui nous rallye
ensemble vers où on veut s'en aller
c'est super important
vous savez notre écosystème notre région
c'est beaucoup plus large que des
structures et ça des fois on l'oubli
derrière les structures il ya des jeunes
des haies mais il ya toute la population
des entrepreneurs bien sûr mais il faut
les rassembler alentours de quelque
chose qui vient les chercher
puis malheureusement on constate
présentement les structures c'est parce
qu'ils l'immobilisme qui comprennent pas
les impacts des des actions qui sont en
train de se prendre donc je vous invite
à aller chercher ces gens là avec ce qui
les anime le plus puis entre filiales
qui ont des intérêts communs je pense
qu'on peut aller très loin avec notre
imagination
la règle numéro 3 dialoguer écouter vous
savez qu'ils écoutent et c'est pas
nécessairement parler mais écouter ce
que les gens ont à dire
vous savez ce qui est le plus important
dans l'intelligence collective c'est que
tout le monde est égal que tout le monde
dit
la diversité des talents c'est important
on est aux différentes caisses qui va
faire que l'on voit émerger comme région
je dirais que ce qui est le plus
important pour ceux qui connaissent
julie bourbonnais je voulais la cité ce
soir il faut vraiment beaucoup de
bienveillante faut que tout se faire
dans un très grand respect et c'est
important
présentement on se divise pas c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va être capable de passer
au deuxième niveau
règle numéro 4 croire en la capacité de
chacun changer notre culture du
management de contrôle ont eu tendance à
attendre de se faire dire quoi faire je
pense qu'on est toutes assez
intelligents pour se reprendre en main
surtout reprendre la culture du risque
vous savez on est un animal et l'animal
dont on n'est plus des animaux mais on
est multi bien sûr mais vous savez qu'on
est habitués de résulter d'un fonds de
réagir au risque et c'est ce que je vous
demande ce que je vous propose
personne ne la bonne réponse y en a pas
juste une bonne réponse
il y en a plusieurs mais il faut risquer
puis accepter de peut-être se tromper je
vous dirais que ce soit je suis très
fort ça se peut que je me trompe mais
pourquoi pas le d'essayer ce qui est
important aussi c'est d'arrêter de juger
le passé on est aujourd'hui on regarde
vers le futur
la règle numéro 5 bien sûr c'est innover
les codes génère une zone d'innovation
assez important depuis génère aussi des
solutions inédites
c'est vraiment important d'écouter
chacun puis de planer sur ces idées là
puis je vous dire jusqu'à maintenant
pour ne pas fini il y en a qui ont des
idées plutôt farfelu charabot
fonctionner donc à pic ont lieu dans le
développement régional
la règle numéro 6 c'est d'avoir du
plaisir d'avoir de la reconnaissance de
la bo de valoriser tout le monde lada on
n'est pas un individu seul on est un nid
de fourmis
donc il faut que chacun soit reconnu et
la dernière règle bien sûr c'est de se
nommer des chefs connecta parce que vous
savez les connecteurs où les parties
prenantes
on peut tous le même langage mais ont
tous la même intention
et je pense que c'est ce qu'on entend
présentement c'est tout le monde ont la
même intention on veut préserver notre
notre région on n'utilise pas toutes le
même langage dans présentement la
plateforme de ce soir me permets de vous
expliquer de vous exprimer ce que ce que
je vis depuis les derniers mois puis
j'imagine que c'est peut-être le co pour
certains d'entre vous mais je ne vois
pas où je nous sens démunis présentement
comme région on essaie de chercher des
coupables on cherche même nos
politiciens j'ai vu des affiches dans
ton mais je pense qu'on a on est des
gens intelligents
on est des gens qui sont capables de
faire prendre sont capables de faire
preuve de grande résilience
donc je vous invite en vert et contre
tous à innover je pense qu'on est
capable de se faire remarquer comme
région puis lui 4 c'est un organisation
je pense qu'ils qui est la preuve qu'on
peut faire des choses envers et contre
tous donc je vous invite vraiment a
utilisé l'exemple de vikas et oui je
vais vous dire que ça sera pas facile
ces sources qui s'en vient par contre je
vous dirais que en se levant tous puis
en étant des leaders en voir tous ces
moments je puis on va regarder vers
l'avenir
puis on va faire comme les fourmis on va
travailler collectivement pour le
développement notre et gens parce que
moi vous nous nous avons
l'abitibi-témiscamingue plus que tout
mais faux